حرب البرق الخاطفه تعثرت وانقلبت الى
معارك استنزاف داميه ساحتها المدن
الاوكرانيه موسكو تتمسك بمكاسبها في
الميدان اما كياف فلا حديثه فيها الا عن
هجوم مضاد تاخر بين عزم ورغبه في الصمود
حرب الربيع لم تنطلق والتغيرات منذ بدايه
العام على خريطه المعارك باتت تقدر
بالامطار بعدما فرض الشتاء اسلوبه في
اقليم دومباس لكن ومع تحسن الطقس وضمن
استراتيجيه تهدف لمحاوله استرجاع الاراضي
الاوكرانيه يتوقع العديد من المراقبين ان
تشن كياف هجوما مضادا على القوات الروسيه
في اي لحظه بعد ان ركزت لاشهر طويله على
تحطيم واستنفاذ احتياطات الجيش الروسي
الاستعدادات اكتملت معدات جديده تم
استلامها ومجندون جاهزون بعد عمليه
التدريب دول حلف الناتو الهجوم المضاد قد
ينطلق في اي لحظه لتتغير معه خريطه
المعارك فاضمن الاستراتيجيه الاوكرانيه
محاصره الجيش الروسي ستكون اولويه وذلك
بشن ضربات مقسمه على عده محاور تقول
القوات الروسيه انها باتت تحت سيطرتها
تفاصيل الهجوم المضاده تشير لحاجه الجيش
الاوكراني لمنطقه زابوريجيا حيث سيسمح
التقدم في هذا الاتجاه للقوات بقطع الجسر
البري الروسي من شبه جزيره القرم الى
دومباس وتعطيل خدمات الجيش الروسيه
اللوجستيه في كلا الجانبين احتمال اخر
مطروح على الطاوله بشان هجوم مضاد محتمل
هو الانطلاق جنوبا وشرقا من خرسون او من
فوغليدار باتجاه فونافاخه او ربما محاوله
قطع الطريق الاستراتيجي المهم بين مدينتي
لوغانسك
في غضون ذلك تبقى معركه مدينه بخموت شرقي
اوكرانيا الاكثر دمويه فباخ موت اصبحت
طعمه ابتلعته كياف الانسحاب بعد مقاومه
ممثله يعد خيانه ومواصله المقاومه ضريبه
يدفعها المئات يوميا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات